meet one of my prodigies Joe who have
learned surfing from me now I know that
when you think about surfing you have to
remember always match in color he is a
communist full of you who do not know
Joe has once killed 14 men with two
chopsticks and one wink last night we at
this place called that kitchen now I did
not vlog there because obviously I was
tired as [ __ ] and they want a vlog at
that point I just wanted to eat so when
I come to Hawaii I always want to local
food local food is something that I
personally enjoy I don't want to come in
Hawaii any hamburger here ik Donald's of
stuff like that so so I had something
else to call the Polynesian paralysis
and that is the actual name and the
kitchen the interesting about the
kitchen is that there portions are
freakin huge and I don't mean sumo-sized
I'm talking about Samoan size like eat
until your penis falls off kind of stuff
we also had something that I really
wanted to try that which was their
deep-fried spam musubi and that was
[ __ ] bomb and by the way it's
pronounced musubi not musubi i got
chastised for that by the way everybody
in Hawaii is very particular about how
you say [ __ ] I'm not allowed to say used
to be I'm not allowed to say uh the itis
is apparently is called a connect attack
so yes after I had a connected ties I
have to take a [ __ ]
oh man
hello everybody and welcome to another
edition of fat free ducks to guide
speciality why are we up here today
today we are here to surf
now surfing is something that you don't
know what it is let me explain to you
surfing is what white people try to do
to connect to us Asian people so they
can float back to the ocean to go to a
different end I know what you are
thinking how come if you know so much
about surfing why don't you serve
yourself well let me explain this to you
I don't want to embarrass anybody as you
know but Quan and Joe it's not so good
at surfing so I don't want to embarrass
them they saw me last time float out
like majestic vietnam unicorn with the
earth with the sparkle with the sparkle
sometimes I wonder why I'm so good at so
many things I am what you call a Jack
Daniel of all trade hello puppy in
Vietnam you I a delicacy when I first
came to this country I came here with
two pennies in my pocket and even then I
lost it
I was out here recording everybody and
in order for me to get a good shot I
have to kind of be in front of
everything so oh [ __ ] I made a stupid
moving Joe was coming at me really fast
and then I decided to move away cuz I
really wanted to get a shot of his face
but what happens is when you do that the
board will come smacking at your face oh
I got really lucky cuz it didn't hit the
phone and it did hit my teeth but as you
can see I'm pretty [ __ ] up bro Kiba
[ __ ] oh yeah [ __ ] it was worth
it Jimmy Dolan if you love it they they
got it out he's speaking like a snowman
he now of course to me you guys all know
traveling has always been about food for
me now we are out here by a roadside and
next to the shrimp run called cess strip
or stay strip I measure this presumption
really the reviews over here people have
been raving about it around here in Maui
and I'm let's see if this shrimp truck
beats Giovanni's now if you guys don't
know about me I am is shrimp connoisseur
as stated before the garlic smells crazy
out here I'm about to get the combo
plate which comes with hot dogs crap
back sell and I believe garlic shrimp or
shrimp scampi so let's get it in aha
it's fresher than the peppermint opening
like a kid again when I beg you notice
tricks like a rabbit it's magic I have
it trapped in a pattern I'm acting like
I'm Aneta confess so automatic behavior
stick now here we come to the part of
the tour well I say hello everybody and
today we are going to get a free song
from me it is a part of the package
called the deluxe golden package
platinum dog do remember you told me you
loved me baby you said you'll be coming
back again sometime baby baby baby baby
oh baby I love you yes I really do that
is a song by my uncle he wrote it
himself